Now for the analysis.
Mostly, I'll just try
to share the intuition.
We want to show that order E
times V augmentations are used.
To see this, we define
something called a level graph.
The level of a vertex is defined
to be the shortest path distance
from the source vertex f.
The level graph then,
is a sub graph of the original,
that includes only those edges from one
level to a level that's one higher.
For example,
if this were my directed graph here,
then the level graph would
be this sub graph down here.
These edges here have been deleted,
because they go between
vertices within the same level.
And this one has been deleted,
because it went backwards or
up a level, in the graph.
We first observed that augmenting
along a shortest path,
only creates paths that are longer ones.
Say that we push flow
along this path here.
Then we've introduced back
edges along this path.
Note, however,
that these edges are useless for
creating a path of the same length.
In fact, because they go back up
a level, any path that uses one of them,
must use two more edges than
the augmenting path that we just used,
the one that was the shortest path.
Next, we observe that
the shortest path distance
must increase every E iterations.
Every time that we use
an augmenting path,
we delete an edge from the level graph.
The edge that got saturated.
Maybe this one here got saturated in
an augmentation along this path, so
we would delete that.
And then maybe we'd push another
flow along this path, and
end up deleting this edge.
These edges won't come
back into the level graph,
until the minimum path
length has increased.
As we've already argued,
the reverse edges are useless.
Until we are allowed
to use a longer path.
So if each augmentation deletes
one edge from the level graph,
then certainly after E iterations,
the level graph would be empty.
And then clearly,
there are no ST paths in this level
graph, and so we need to build a bigger
one that includes longer paths in order
to be able to augment any further.
And lastly, there are only V
possible shortest path lengths.
So that completes the theorem.
For each possible path link,
we might have up to E iterations.
Going back to the theorem, note that
we've eliminated the dependence to
the running time on the capacities.
This means that the algorithm
is now strongly polynomial.
And actually,
we can eliminate the requirement that
the capacities be integers entirely.